[Música]
y con eso primero invitaba el día
seguimos analizando entonces las
implicaciones de este primer lanzamiento
de la misión artemis de la nasa que como
lo venimos hablando tiene previsto que
envíe hombres a la luna en el año 2025 y
por ello entonces saludamos a nuestro
invitado el césar fuentes astrónomo de
la universidad de chile e investigador
del centro de astrofísica cata phd en
astrofísica césar gracias por estar con
nosotros en directo américa de france 24
empezamos entonces dando un poco de
contexto la importancia de esta misión
artemis porque además nos tardamos tanto
tiempo desde 1992 que el ser humano y
las agencias espaciales del mundo sobre
todo la nasa no se volcaba a ir
nuevamente a la luna porque ahorita
hola buenos días un gusto estar hablando
con esta noticia que estamos empezando a
volver a la luna con todo lo que eso
significa y respondiendo tu pregunta por
qué nos amamos tanto bueno porque han
habido otras prioridades para las
agencias espaciales
después de la guerra fría que lo cierto
uno mira como que ganó eeuu a rusia oa
lo que nos oriente que en esta carrera
para llegar a la luna los rusos tomaron
la mejor idea de seguir con una
presencia en el espacio a través de la
mira
esta idea fue recogida después por el
resto de las potencias en esto que es la
estación espacial orbital internacional
y entremedio no pasó mucho más en
exploración porque no tenía tanto
sentido después de todos los viajes que
se volvieron a hacer a la luna el
retorno por cada esfuerzo fue cada vez
menor y mucha de esa tecnología se fue
perdiendo los estos cohetes saturn que
fueron los los que llevaron al hombre a
la luna esa tecnología toda esa esa
inteligencia se fue perdiendo a través
de los años que nada se movió a esto de
los transbordadores que fueron bastante
importantes para por ejemplo
y enviar instrumentos fantásticos como
el hubble que ahora hace poco fue
reemplazado y comenzando a ser expresado
por el lleida hoy este
con una idea que era recuperar estos
estos aviones para que volvieran a la
tierra y últimamente gracias a la
entrada de privados y el desarrollo
tecnológico propio de estos últimos 50
años que tiene mucho que ver con la
computación la industria del software
hemos visto cómo ha ido bajando el costo
para enviar cosas al espacio y en este
nuevo puig por volver a la luna en el
contexto de una nueva isla pérez carrera
tecnológica con china y otros actores
esto es los retos principales de esta
misión cuáles serían
bueno partiendo por el tamaño del cohete
y la potencia que uno necesita para ir a
la luna y entrar en esta órbita
hace tiempo que estamos viendo como
otras potencias como china y ya tiene
una presencia en la luna
a través de estos los autitos a control
remoto de estos drones que se mueven en
la superficie así como nasa y otras
países también tienen presencia en marte
por ejemplo entonces se marca un poco
dentro de esa idea de seguir con la
exploración humana en presencia humana
en el sistema solar y los principales
problemas tienen que ver con
lo que es más difícil que es salir de la
gravedad terrestre
que es el momento más crítico entonces
esto que se haya trazado ahora creo que
por media hora que tiene que ver con
aquí el punto más crítico quien en el
momento en que el despegue y luego
esperamos de una exitosa misión en su 10
de octubre con el aterrizaje de este
módulo que está haciendo la prueba para
antes de mandar gente a orbitar la luna